With all this background
on the event-driven model,
we will now talk about the Flash paper.
Flash is an event-driven webserver that
follows the AMPED model, so basically it
has asymmetric helper processes to
deal with the blocking guy operations.
In the discussion so far, we really
described the architecture of Flash.
So it uses helper processes for
blocking I/O operations.
And then everything else is implemented
as an event dispatcher with
handlers performing different
portions of the web servicing tasks.
Given that we are talking about a web
server, and this is the old fashioned
Web 1.0 technology where basically the
web server just returns static files.
The blocking I operations that
are happening an the system are really
just disk reads, so the server just
reads files that the client requests.
The communication from the helpers to
the event dispatcher is performed via
pipes.
The helper reads the file in memory via
the mmap call, and then the dispatcher
checks the in-operation mincore,
if the pages of the file are in memory.
And it then uses this information
to decide if it should just
call one of the local handlers, or if it
should pass the request to the helper.
As long as the file is in memory,
reading it won't result in a blocking
I/O operation, and so passing it to
the local handlers is perfectly okay.
Although this is an extra check that has
to be performed before we read any file,
it actually results in big savings
because it prevents the full process
from being blocked if it turns out that
a blocking I/O operation is necessary.
Now we will outline some additional
detail regarding some of
the optimization that Flash applies.
And this will help us later understand
some of the performance comparisons.
The important thing is that these
optimizations are really relevant to any
web server.
First of all,
Flash performs application-level
caching at multiple levels.
And it does this on both data and
computation.
What we mean by this is,
it's common to cache files.
This is what we call data caching.
However, in some cases it makes
sense to cache computation.
So in the case of the web server, the
requests are requests for some files.
These files need to be
repeatedly looked up.
So you need to find the file,
traverse the directory,
look up some of the directory
data structures.
That processing will
compute some results.
So some location,
some pathname for the file.
And we will just cache that.
We don't have to recompute that and
look up the same information next time
a request for that same file comes in.
Similarly in the context
of web processing,
the HTTP header that files have
that are returned to the browser,
it's really going to
depend on the file itself.
So a lot of the fields in there are file
dependent given that the file doesn't
change.
The header doesn't have to change so
this is another type of
application level caching that we
can perform and Flash does this.
Also Flash does some optimizations
that take advantage of the networking
hardware and the network interface card.
For instance all of the data
structures are aligned so
that it's easy to perform DMA
operations without copying data.
Similarly, they use DMA operations
that have scatter-gather support, and
that really means that the header and
the actual data don't have to be
aligned one next to another in memory.
They can be sent from
different memory locations, so
there's a copy that's avoided.
All of these are very useful techniques,
and are now fairly common optimizations.
However, at the time the paper was
written, they were pretty novel, and
in fact,
some of the systems they compare against
did not have some of
these things included.